Dr Anthony found she's lashing out at
Republicans and Elon Musk for calling on
him to be prosecuted watch this
there's no response to that craziness
Jim I mean prosecute me for what what
are they talking about I mean I wish I
could figure out what the heck they were
talking about I think they're just going
off the deep end and just to follow up
on the musk part back in December musk
tweeting my pronouns are prosecute slash
fouchy what's your reaction all this Joe
well it's good to see Dr fauci run to
his best friend in Jim Acosta and try to
again is there a microphone that Anthony
fauci hasn't liked that he has to run on
TV all the time and and talk about
himself basically look it is clear now
that Dr fauci is a compromised man who
was not truthful with the American
people about covet's Origins that it
very much looks like now that logic is
winning out per the FBI per the
department of energy that coronavirus
that originated in Wuhan China may have
come from a lab in Wuhan China that
studies coronavirus through something
called gain of function research that
fauci's department funded and advocated
and now more than 1.1 million people
here in this country in the US are dead
8.4 million worldwide there needs to be
accountability and that starts with Dr
fauci and it will be very very
interesting to watch uh Rand Paul for
example the senator from Kentucky
Republican questioning Dr fauci when he
appears on Capitol Hill because he's got
no excuses to hide behind at this point
and we need to know how this happens so
we don't have it happen again that's how
you learn you learn from mistakes you
learn from these situations and we can't
have coveted 25 that that I know because
this country cannot go through what it
went through particularly for America's
children who are now what 30-year low in
test scores as a result of stay-at-home
learning through covid that Dr fauci
advocated by the way as well you know
really quickly Joe Friday
Intel about the origins of copen19 and
it
didn't ask what do you think is going to
come of that
he should sign it I would think
considering that this wasn't a
pass-through party lines sort of
situations
miss strawheimer this is something that
he must sign because Republicans
Democrats Independents everybody wants
to know how this happened and wants to
know who needs to be held accountable
all right Joe Concha thanks so much good
to see you on a Monday hope you had a
good you have a good birthday weekend
the husband treat you well I had a lot
of Pizza and Pasta
Morning Joe all right good to hear thank
you Joe take care guys